looking a little rough around the edges
so let's judge other people's
appearances how many was recent baby do
not know now you know it's different now
VMAs happened over the weekend let's
review some of the red carpet fashions
or whatever I mean was like a hologram
carpet I don't know what do they do kids
these days I hate myself your opposite I
would likely miss people that you wanted
me to talk about so I'm sorry I can't
please all of you subscribe Kesha you
look like a cake topper that has some
chucks in your tits what this is cool
you like glenda the goodwitch that also
knows karate look like Chuck Norris is
fairy godmother
you know Haley Baldwin Wow like you walk
through the most beautiful spider web or
like all of the blood in your veins just
froze looks like a unicorn came off okay
very cute
Palestine feel Steve your Stern's dance
to monsterpiece beer I love sting you
look adorable
this was very my super-sweet Grecian 16
like an elementary school art class made
a bunch of fans and tape them into a
dress for you cute thank you Minaj oh
just a badass girl Bow Wow bring pink
pepto-bismol 8x10 Cooter's gotta be in
pain you who needs Spanx when your
outfit is Thanks the shoes look like hot
Couture Power Rangers you look like more
like a sex blow-up doll that definitely
probably just like talks about you
behind your back when you leave the room
yeah pink what bank did you just come
from I think it's awesome
I love when women wear more masculine
attire they're like a very fashionable
version of the monopoly man you can't
remove Wall Street and you just got done
doing blow off with some girl's vagina
you checked your pocket watching right
oh my god the VMAs are starting
[Music]
scammer what yeah Billy Bobby Brown
you're just growing up before our eyes
that's creepy to say you look adorable
and uncomfortable like they let you out
of boot camp for the day and you didn't
have a dress to wear to the ball so you
just took the shower curtain and did
what you could cute Mel B well I'll be
damned that you're bi looks amazing Wow
you will never own me is what the dress
says that seems like a direct message to
someone she's not signing into anyone's
DM she's just messaging directly Jim
harmony I heard they threw shade at
Camila
this is the most disconnected that
they've looked to me on a red carpet is
this a sign that they might I don't know
conspiracy theories sorry
you all look absolutely beautiful you
all look like you're not in the same
group but that's okay Obama is holding a
birdcage because duh I like this sexy
red thing I can't tell if it's a dress
or if it's a jumpsuit or if it's how
it's on your body but beautiful and the
birdcage nothing says I don't need
attention like carrying a birdcage down
the Olivia Munn I love this dress I want
to own it that's all
you look great Lord O Lord so much and
some might say this is an awkward stance
but I think this is just lowered being
Lord she killed a snuffleupagus and then
dip died an ace bandage who called it a
dress and I'm all for it
hey Perry this is geometrically
confusing but your tits look great is as
cool like a Picasso painting on your
body space Sharon Stone cute no Cyrus or
any 16 to 20 year old YouTube your girl
I think this is fun it's like you got
your boyfriend sweatshirt and your
dominatrix moms boots stone and dark
glasses and your
grandma's choker and you made it work
cute mr. Hudgens this is cool I think
that netting makes me feel a little
claustrophobic you look like you got
little Mama's birdcage and the bottom
half of your body cute this is Amber
Rose which think guys the internet knows
because I would never have known you
look beautiful with brown hair you look
like a pageant queen you look like a wax
figure also are you okay
blink if you need help okay
cute Shawn Mendes looking like Shawn
Mendes is America's Sweetheart and does
your shirt AB s is an M comment Shawn
Mendes someone is upping their branding
game Thank You Paris Jackson gods and
goddesses on this netting thing but it's
over like a painter way rotten underwear
said bury Coachella meets fruit of the
Loom cute GG gorgeous you just you do it
every time how do you do it every day
this looks very like what you wear under
your wedding dress on your wedding night
that you're like here we go carry me
across the threshold and let's seal this
deal Jim this is Machine Gun Kelly this
is what Machine Gun Kelly who's looked
like this whole time why did you guys
tell me this he's the baby he's very
attractive baby I'm moving on Jay
Versace oh my god this kid is so funny
and he looks like a cartoon character
and I love it and he's having a great
time and I love it you look like a box
of Crayola Crayons
puked all over mr. Rogers I'm here for
it Demi Lovato whoa this is like a sex
genie cool I like these glitter harem
pants with this lace thing well looks
like you got a bunch of henna all over
the top half here we come and it feels
great
then give me those harem pants you put
your pants so many times during the show
and no one would have any idea cute
andrea russett it you look like a
princess oh my god doors look so badass
unlike rocker punk
chic that I sound so old right now
this is so soft and demure and pretty
look at you I'm so proud of you this is
like hygiene goals ass okay I know I
probably missed a ton of people that you
want me to comment on so for that again
I am sorry but let me know what you
thought of the looks at the VMAs this
year leave a comment down below click
subscribe because I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday sometimes I don't
and sometimes I do it differently said
don't know why I keep saying that and
other than that I don't know Heidi Klum
is there a girl is back I was missing
her and a lot of events lately and I'm
really glad she made this one and damn
boi-oi-oi-oi-oing her hair looks so
healthy